[Music]
guys this is not a drill I repeat this
is not a drill we're actually getting
descendants three the announcement went
viral on Twitter but wait until you see
the reaction some of the casts made to
cast members were so excited they did
the splits if you're new here make sure
to subscribe to the things and give our
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the descendants cast reaction to the
third movie announcement squealing this
was dove Cameron's reaction and there's
no better way to describe it she pretty
much squealed in a video and it was
insanely cute the official Twitter
account for descendants posted a
hilarious video of Doug getting her hair
and makeup day and she was totally
squealing in the high pitch and moving
around way too much as she was getting
her hair fixed props to the hairdresser
for being able to do their job all while
Doug clearly messed around and probably
made their work a million times more
difficult the entire scene was totally
adorable
Doug also said that this is a big deal
for the entire cast and they didn't even
know it was happening for sure until
just a few days before the announcement
imagine how exhausting it must be when
fans ask you about the third movie but
you can't tell them anything because you
don't even know you'll be in it until
the last minute Kenny Ortega is
definitely playing with their hearts she
also said she absolutely loved the promo
and she wished she could tell us more
all while having a fabulous haircut done
in the process we're not sure what's
cuter her haircut or her reaction to the
descendants three announcements welcome
back well he's not a part of the cast
Kenny Ortega is too you'll have to thank
for descendants as well as a bunch of
other movies including High School
Musical he was even the man behind
Michael Jackson's This Is It movie it's
safe to say we wouldn't have descendants
without this genius Kenny Ortega left a
series of Twitter messages and Instagram
posts thanking every single cast member
and officially welcoming them back on
the team each message has been retweeted
and liked hundreds of times and you can
tell the fans got more and more excited
with each announcement his adorable
messages included telling Cameron that
Cruella would have been proud of she
could see him now and said long live
purple as he welcomed back dub he had a
special message for each cast member the
message also links to an Instagram video
for each cast member shared another
reaction and an announcement that
they're officially back on The
Descendants team can he even thanked the
fans and called them to cinders which is
the name we've officially been given
phandom aren't Kenny's Twitter messages
totally adorable thankful do you
remember when Sophia Carson talked about
descendants to and she said it's always
nerve-wracking to do a sequel because
the fans expect so much and you never
know how well-received it would be until
it actually premieres on the big screen
she then said that the second one was
actually pretty exciting to do and she
was even surprised to hear that they
have fans in Brazil and Tokyo but her
reaction to the third movie hit us right
in the fields she didn't squeal or do
any insane acrobatics like the ones
we'll show you in a few minutes but her
message was incredibly thoughtful and it
showed that without their fans these
movies definitely wouldn't be as
successful it's always the demand that
makes these movies possible and Sophia
makes it clear that the entire cast is
aware this couldn't have happened
without the fans she shared The
Descendants announcement and tagged all
her cast members including Kenny Ortega
she then wrote that this is for the fans
and because of the fans before adding a
thank-you we're not crying you are
that was completely adorable and we
loved seeing them be so thankful we
really did it guys our love for the
movies definitely got the message heard
time to update the hashtag Chyna and
McClain had a very good point when she
posted her Twitter reaction to the
exciting news she shared a cute seven
second video of her chanting descendants
three to show her excitement but above
her video she wrote that it's time to
update the hashtag which is totally true
we've been using the descendants to hash
tag for long enough to make an impact
and tell everyone how much we loved it
and now it's time to ditch saying
descendants too because there's a new
favorite movie in town sure we might not
see it until summer 2019 but what better
way to get excited over it than to hype
it up on Twitter using the dissonance 3
has tagged and let's not forget that
using this hashtag will also show the
team how many people love the movie
which probably means we might even get
the fourth one we never want the
descendants story to end so China is
definitely right it's time to update the
hashtag and start talking about the
third movie we're definitely on board
with this one her reactions getting us
to pumped the splits the final reaction
had us in stitches literally because we
tried doing this and we failed of course
when you're on the dissonance casts you
really have to master all kinds of
impressive acrobatics but when you and
your BFF can sync while doing them it
really creates an iconic video you can
tell that the descendants cast really
are excited and thankful to have a
chance to act in the third movie that
looks like Cameron voice and booboo
Stewart got caught in rehearsals when
they shared an Instagram reaction to the
descendants three news the two both
celebrated by sharing an Instagram
boomerang of them effortlessly hitting
those splits
they look so in sync it's pretty
impressive they're able to get in the
splits with a single jump instead of
prepping for them to make sure they're
properly stretched that's definitely
something not everyone can do we just
hope that means we'll be getting some
gymnastics action in the next movie can
you imagine them doing the splits on
screen please Disney let's make this
happen and add their splits to a musical
number we promise we'll replay that
already iconic scene over and over again
what was your reaction when you heard
the descendants three announcements let
us know in the comments that's it for
our video don't forget to subscribe to
the things and hit that like button for
more videos like this one see you next
time
[Music]